So i am still a fast made. All of the cake. And jack. Join all of them. In my. Oh. I on sale of the gate and.
I think into the saying. I was born a year. About a year after.
My parents john oliver and john gave me the name infancy need. I was their first child. And i lived on.
Paradise valley. To their economy in the stead of nimbin and to was about full time until i was about eight. I think.
And my dad made it into lee's mill. And i decided to live with him and visit. Mom.
Have you want to put a guy who paid a good shot. On weekends and. That's when i cam john on my feet in basically.
I was one of the first time. Also a few years later around two years after my sister. I was numb the.
Number seven baby born on the community. First and first buried behind in the community. I see i live.
Two hours about i. Way out of my mother. On new follow that stage moved down here to bar by just. Nearby.
Dr i she was photonic to about the age of eight. Earliest memories of. Would have on the community.
With a wide range of friends. Just as. My memory is just one big happy family. I see only.
There was no major mother figure major father figure. Everyone to turn to anyone for any help. Anything.
You know i was a big happy family.
Well i have a lot of memories
and i actually been thinking about it because people say oh my first memory is of my mom doing useless and i that.
I don't really know exactly what. All my memories fit in. And i that. Tonka toys. I don't actually.
Let's really talk about these big family thing i don't really remember a lot of the parents like parents always there
were navy nay them. But they went to be part of my life and i probably would but honest.
Members and i'm basically a member
or a group of friends like there was jamie entirely in all these people who are older than me
and then there was a group of friends who in my eyes and those those who are younger than us
and of those this one particular place where used. All the older.
The older guys had tonka toys and we'd make tonka toy cities in.
Mud really just i mean just having so much fun in the outdoors like.
I don't know if i ever had a lot of toys but artist noise that.
I didn't have to have something material in my hands i mean.
Yeah i could just go outside and we might mud pies and bring them into mom
and she'd go being being being cooked i mean you have and then we get side and eat them so i have to say.
The airways memories are just of. Having a whole lot of fun. Just. With these group of friends. Like children and.
I mean there were adult. Influences but basically just the kids. Having so much fun. Would have to be you know i yeah.
Bush experience. A lot of exploring. Too i think two hundred ten eyck of. Anyway.
Quite a large farm for small kids to explore. And so you know.
There's there's a great waterfall there with the big swimming how much bicycling the community lived around in the
summer. You know to swim everyday and those. Some with lots of kids our age older and younger sally mentioned so.
They used to be a lot of tricks off into the bush just by ourselves.
You know like that we had the freedom to do that didn't have to be supervised. You know.
We didn't have supervision i was just paper joined. But you know i would head off into the bush and.
Those are lots of experience with the bush and. You know a lot of animals on the phone a lot of fun with that.
Now i've lived in. Cycle suburbia i guess.
Is what most people want to hear when i say the bush experiences things like. It's really.
At one stage we did have i mean we always had sam i've never been seven. Living with dad.
Every house has been in his same i built houses sort of things but.
Because i know i think he says to another because like.
My parents in the people who set up the community came straight from the sea.
Are always remember there was always a bathroom and there was always a kitchen. I mean.
So it wasn't like we mean we still had to use the gas lamps every. You know. That the main the.
The bottom house which was what was the first. Regional buildings always had electricity.
And always had all the light is mud cons basically i mean that's the way i saw it.
But the bush experience from a water to spain. As janice said.
We were just given the freedom and the trust i think that's. I mean i.
It wasn't a conscious thing then but reflecting back. I mean you know my kid. Friends say oh and you know.
Mom wouldn't let me do this mom going to let me do that and. I mean. Yeah the creek.
Was a major source we'd just go for. Day explorations up the creek and weed.
I know i wouldn't exactly said i would know how to build my own house although i'm sure. My mom would disagree. That.
You know base self-sufficient you know because. I think as kids we were really not asked to do a lot. I mean. You know.
We didn't have trolls. As such we were just given the freedom to explore and i mean.
I think the so-called bush experiences has just given me.
And i you just you know i haven't meant so much technical things of. How to set up. You saw deviousness.
Nice city folk being that.
That's what the experience is all about
but it's it's kind of i await of life the way of looking at things sort of like.
Ok you've got a tall waterfall and you want to get to the top. You know i had to do it so i think he's like.
And if that's answer the question. You know why. I remember. My biological father mother of three the school.
Actually he started the community school that i went to which played a big part in my life.
So it's quite interesting relighting them relating to them as parents as well as my teacher.
And it was a very interesting way to relight as i'm you know i wasn't a father figure or a mother figure. You know.
Was someone there to. That was no way should we get out of them and stuff. But in a fun y.
All remember a lot of a lot of good times laughing times with them. But i always seem to be busy.
Happy and always ready to share share the parenting like was unlike the white man who was lucky. She was happy to.
Lotus or found other people and. We could spend time with so. So it was an interesting experience with a nice school.
So i guess. The key really to school. I guess i knew. On into hammy's i went there.
The main thing at the community school armand is kid circus. And a curious school.
Was into buildings there was the can really school which is being old commonwealth bank i think.
And that was the main school and ahead. And i i mean it wasn't like a school because there was rooms.
But there was a kitchen and and. Because it was like it was like a house really more than a bank and.
So you know we do cooking. As in home science but it would be. I mean.
The same and nimbin in the way one taught in the community school was. It wasn't like.
You're going to learn how to make these it's. Oh yeah well. If you managed to make it at the end that's fine.
But all the lessons along the way is more important i still had this one memory of. We're making.
Toffee i think it was and. As it was one stove and.
Ten people making coffee and i had two people play a part we're staring where you. And the.
By the time the last person had cooked their tuffy and.
Ready to go to the next say it's a first person's toffee was had. So here was our first lesson and.
And then there was the lesson of. If we use a metal spoon we're going to get hot.
But if we use a wooden spoon it's going to burn.
And if we use a plastic spoon is going to melt so which option is the best. I mean i have all these crazy memories.
But. I mean it's just great i mean basically. I have lots of just. Stories and memories from the community school.
The other party community schools the t.a.'s all the tomato sauce. And the tomato sauce arm and the as.
The kid circus space and wood. Woodworks price down malone and. And pottery. Poetry was we had a little.
Wheel on things like that and. I have to tell you the story. I was real young and. We had.
We were going at the moment decided we're going to start doing cindy exhausting.
And so she said right we're going out to get the jigsaw.
Beauty thoughts out this is great i want to get to show all my friends my new camera. The frog and miss piggy.
Did so a puzzle that i had just got the other day. So we rocked. You know.
Mom we had a basket he was going to drive back to pave a and. Mom got outby wood to work.
Jigsaw that cuts wood and so he's going. That doesn't look like my t. Saw.
So i mean that's the way you kind of learn things it was like. I mean really in that i had great fun and i mean.
Our members.
Have to i'm kind of got all these stories
and i can only tell you because they just why is it wrong that not answering a question that they can really do school
on members being on him when i first went to a so-called. Proper. I don't know where you want to go public school.
Really worried that i wouldn't be up to scratch. But. I now realize that i case i maybe there wasn't you know.
The heaviest. Emphasis on. Let's getting the academic work. But i lent. So many other things.
So many important things about life i mean. Not. You know great loss stories i mean you know nothing like that.
But just so many things. That is changed. And i made the way i am that you really would have gotten.
In an ordinary school because i mean just.
And you know just the why it was taught as a start with an i mean i mean business. Kid circus i mean.
Hey i could talk that. The kid circles are have to say. When the community school first. We had a day a week.
I think i was on my quite sure i was so young artist remember.
And it was just a major influence in my life i was a klan. Later on i got nine. Barely pants but.
A when i first started i don't think i had a name. I was just a clown. And i remember we did this.
And i got our performance. Together and. And we do it and it same to me that.
We may as well have gone to seed me and it turned out now that we only went to ballad but the travel
and the excitement and things like that and i think i mean now there's no way i can get up on stage
and do all that sort of stuff that i used to like. I could but i would go home get only embarrassed. With that just.
It was good that it didn't give you the confidence that.
Oh i'm so wonderful and all this sort of stuff but it gave you. Confidence in yourself.
You didn't think that you were better than anyone else just because you were on stage. You didn't think that.
Oh i know you just.
You just thought you felt really so confident in yourself and you saw this is great
and i just remember having so much fun. I mean the community schools are right. It was like. I mean.
Oh i can i mean i can remember specifically lessons.
Are communal one specific lesson of learning about the parts of a frog. And i mean you're.
Like i don't remember any of this sort of stuff from. You know.
Public schools it's all just all year where we wanted to spell we went to a want to write. But just.
I don't know if it was because it was that stage in my life but i'm in this specific incidence and.
Things like that just really stand there and. God helps me get through my boy economics periods that. I may have.
My friends still. They still guy. Do you think it's really and.
Now you're just joking at me when i was really in a second so i tell my story then.
Yeah the community school is just yeah as i said taught you a lot of stuff.
Not necessarily strict academic stuff but it's pretty damn fun. Yeah i'd go along with that.
Just the stall in which i taught it. My i've lots of memories of the community school. But no one is actually learning.
Like being sat down
and saying learn this you have to not for tests no tests not nothing like that basically is the sharing of knowledge to
the younger kids. I mean. I remember going to actual. Public school.
For a short period of time and being you know you know there's going to be like proper academic questions with math
and thing. I sat down in a class with kids my age. Not actually think you have ever done mass. Sat down with questions.
And i breezed through them. I was at the top of the class. By big majority right.
When he was always like my teacher thought here. I mean i had. I had a rat's tile my hair was shaved i was a rat's.
You know i didn't have a uniform i was just you know i was just a little hippie kid with. You know.
Shocked everyone and here i was why i had everyone else in my schooling. Academia saw it and.
I think the community school was just wonderful. Really was i mean sad mention the circus thousand credible.
That really was. Our main. I think the biggest thing that i still have is the memory where. Also a dog.
And i had to go out and do a certain saying that i came in early. But of course the.
Well what you know i didn't know but to me it was a big thing yard coming early in my act and. Oh no what should i do.
You know to things as close as a little kid that was important to me
but i remember several scenes in like in performing in front of like it seemed like everyone in the moon would come out
to say. I remember. For me in the data factory. It's a big concert. The whole thing and we did a performance and.
It seemed like everyone in my whole world of nimbin was there watching us on stage
and i was a real bad so there's a really good things out there. It's incredible but.
I mean like doing the aboriginal studies. You know.
I mean this day and night i mean you know i just better go and you ten. And like.
You know you learn about a struggle jaan. Sure you do. Aboriginals and our night. But you don't learn a.
Really about them. We had a man who just knew so much about them we took camping trips up in rivers. And we go and we.
Bicycle live. Like them and learnt about them and. Like them and. It was just incredible like.
You know here we were only young. But learning just incredible skills and knowledge that.
There's so many about they just won't know. Probably the whole loft and here we were through the community school.
You know.
Learning about such things as that was incredible
and i said that that was disappointed janice said was amazing was that we learned. Sign that. It was. I mean.
Maybe because it wasn't categorized into.
This is what you know and you see and this is what you know and next year i have to say that.
Although it was different. The amount that i've lent.
Well i can only say it because the time spans different the set in manama in the time span i was in human
and then there same time span outside. Was just. Although i learnt a lot of other things.
It was just as i said all my memories from. Nimbin all my childhood there. Please.
Every memory that i always go back and chuckle on. Is foam.
Before i left which was when i was i so i as have i have to say we just saw a match. It was.
I mean basically it just provided a whole dice. I mean as. Mom was saying ilya.
Having all these different influences and not having me. Teach our student relationship. Not having met. You know that.
So-called relationship. It was good because you wouldn't just say. They just want to sort of thing you think. Well.
Or respect this person so actually going to want to learn about what they have to share and i think.
Having such a number of adults and a really broad base. Manes that. We were able to.
Really say well i think that idea is right
and i think that idea is wrong in just that community school the whole atmosphere and environment. Really lettuce.
And just so much just really self that i think is really important to base your character for the rest of the act.
And actually learning all of it. Like us might not have said before wasn't in a teaching my.
As such as we're used to in this. You know. Schooling system.
We wouldn't sit down in class and psycho we're going to learn this. As such and learn that you have to now it. It was.
I can't remember being taught as such something direct. We just learnt it.
In that do it in practice by sickly they want to teach or something would go
and do it so we'd learn from it is served out of a textbook. You know.
We want to learn about the oceans and how it worked would go to the ocean.
Would spend away camping on it and would learn about it much more than. Learn reading out of a textbook.
You know it was just incredible the way they taught it to us i think it was a mine. Thing that matters learned so much.
Yes. There was. There was the public school which was just down the road.
And there so there's a community school in the public school. But i think the whole of.
Really just learn to integrate and one that wasn't wasn't. Segregation like you know rednecks and.
Hillbillies the like in america nothing like that basically. That i can recall.
I think though i have to disagree with that has different memories and.
It wasn't there was i wouldn't even say separation that's too strong a word. There was this.
The words of difference in separation too strong.
There were people who went to the community school and they were the people who went to human sensual.
And every lunch times i used to track up by their luncheon.
Some top of the state we used to have the good old oh yes and i used to hassle us and we still has a limb.
But guy i'm on the bus together we're all friends so it was like it was there. But i never really think it got to the.
It never was you know and tegan you stick around and if that's right word i'm not going to be on english
but it was just. It was there because i think we i don't know if we had. It was that.
That was you know that society those groups or. If we were just having fun because.
Hey why not because i don't know if that's even made sure not
but it never in my experience never was anything more than a friendly joke.
I mean i mean it model been for the older kids but.
I mean as i said going home on a bus that wasn't a problem you know there was no.
You sitting next to who you want anything at that because i think i know. It was just. Those two different schools and.
You know we all. We all still. Had you know. Still human so it wasn't really a problem i think that was good.
Having being out and i thought was because it was my age.
I was still in that kind of naive group where everybody is my friend in that.
You know i think that's just another thing and if we got out of nimbin it was like. Well it doesn't matter.
You know i mean it doesn't matter if that person's driving a.
You know miss avies news person driving a bomb dropped their friends their friends sort of being in. I think that was.
Yeah. That was really. Yeah and of the ball that us really. One memory.
If you could call it memories of not having any memory of ever getting in trouble.
Various friends and i say i face memory and then my mom he me or something like that which is. And i mean i remember.
Without going into specific detail. A few. Myself and a few friends. Demolished a certain spice of the person.
I don't know that we even really had a reason we did. To begin with but then i think we've got carried away with.
Demolishing the spice basically in all of its contents. And in there. As soon as we'd finished.
Were absolutely horrified it ourselves i mean. Wade. We were crying and shaking just at the thought of.
Because we know. We knew what he had done was just sorry wrong it was just so out of law it was just.
I mean basically we knew we'd been totally irresponsible and. And i guess also because we knew that we deserved to.
You know. Not have lost trust but. I mean we knew that we'd broken trust and.
And i remember we were just absolutely terrified.
But we said right well we've got to we've done these horrific acts you know we've got to do this. So we.
And i don't even remember an angry voice. I don't remember. A person saying. Oh. Tough time.
I mean i really doubt all our members have in their state newspaper between pages of what books that have been left
there have not and. But i don't i think that. It was a situation where. It wasn't like we could get away with it.
But it wasn't what we got in trouble somehow we. We.
We knew we learned from the whole process and learned that what we done was wrong and. You know went on from there.
Without having to be yelled at i mean basically i was. I was never yelled at. I mean. Oh that's not true.
Well yes it is actually our day. I mean i don't know if it's this good all that's block out the bad memories but.
I mean we all had our disagreements and i remember. John and i used to fart like. Tears in that.
But even our even this is classic memory even when we were fighting.
He still used to call me sour and i still used to call him. Bines.
But we became sell to do that and they are in usually you know in some good thing you know.
So we obviously come down here sort of being and. Yeah i mean. I'm in the general i used to not get on.
But we used to get on sort of being but. Now i never went. When disciplined. Yet we didn't turn out to be raucous.
Oh ok. We orchestrated. We didn't turn out to be our you know.
Rebels to society
or anything like that it was just think it was respect just make sure it's basically art full young so i said like.
There was never i mean i remember one case. There was a very clear.
There was nothing on the fame on one mile didn't matter a thing. All our friends.
It was just a group of kids didn't matter girls didn't matter boys. You know. Being naked.
Didn't mean a thing you know he's around the font family. You know. Didn't matter but.
I mean i remember for some reason. This girl came out. Said hi jonah. And i hit it.
I mean i was the first time of ever hit someone in my life i think. I hear. I i stood there i didn't know why he died.
And she just today didn't know why he. I you know i hear this and then she started crawling him on and i went to bed.
Which is just another mother figure and said oh not to come across said what happened to hit me so she comes
and everything. And then beth comes out i mean what did you hit it john i said.
Sort of because she said whoa all right. Oh that's all i could think of all right.
Ok i don't know ration to be shaking so i knew i'd never be hit or anything
but still the fact i'd done something wrong you know. And she goes. Well that's right.
I take no shit from nobody if i say hello to him. So the why of the why you know like disciplining people.
Was it a little light hearted.
Funny well i mean she could say that i didn't mean it knows no while going to continue to do it but it was just yeah.
Just cases like that which i think. I think it's incredible why we brought out. I mean it's really benefited.
I think may i think it was a litle off down hard just the way we were light.
To last and everything is totally different because of our childhood upbringing.
I think also just the way we would have made us.
I mean just reflecting just now on what jenna said and when i say we both knew that we done something wrong and.
I mean. Before we even so-called confessed. Seems out of that. We knew that. That was just tell what and it was like.
I think that another caller id that we've got out of you know how we've been brought up. Is that.
The rate only maybe the reason there wasn't such discipline. Was there wasn't a need for it. I mean.
I don't know if that was just i mean that was probably why we bought out we knew that that was right.
And that was wrong i mean. Yeah i mean. We still had disagreements.
I mean i remember there was big disagreement i have my vegetable ating habits and stuff like that.
This is this very title he was the one we used to cram twenty paper on
and i used to hate visuals so i used to pass the law right now turn my head in.
Under the table and one day he pays a brothel i think hit mom on the leg and she looked.
And there was dr contents of my plight and. A will. And i think. I mean that wasn't my issue but.
Finally he was also and he kind of all the considered you my older brother decided.
Because i has thing that he said look to slaver line. She's surviving. I think of something like that and they did.
I mean. I'm still not liking them vegetables but i'm not dying in. Yeah it was. It was. That was another thing that.
Their parents. Adults had respect for the kids. It wasn't like oh yes. Nice deal what if he said i just go why imply.
And so i think that. Because we were given respect. We could give respect and trust back.
And so when we done something wrong we just say look i've done this wrong and.
But it was a thing and spit out what so you said earlier about type. Bring your older brother.
That's one thing which on the community. Was a big thing. Like outside it was a huge family. I mean i see.
Jamie all these guys and. And girls on the farm. As my older brothers and sisters and younger brothers and sisters.
Biologically. Ok we weren't. But we were just as close. Like you know like. If not close if we had troubles like.
When i was just little. Carry me around driving around in a cardboard box and. I see they testify they believe hartson.
You know is just one big happy family with the hate of parents right. And i hate brothers and sisters. It wasn't like.
Doll that family that are under that name and we were here. By sickly. Brothers and sisters. You know.
Just really good. Have to say that.
Now being attain a so-called adolescent teenager
and talking with all my friends i would just have to say that my child would have to be. Probably the happiest. I mean.
Living it. I could not have wanted it any other way. It was just.
I mean i don't know if i'd want to live there now because i have manus so it's hard to say. But it was just.
It was just me going through
and living it i was just thinking oh this is pretty normal doesn't everyone leave like these i mean.
I didn't really think that but i just said i had this is great i am heaven he's a fun and fantastic but.
Looking back you know fretting and all that sort of stuff. I'll just have to say that it was just unbelievable.
I can't. I still i mean it shocks me myself i still to sit back and go. Wow. I just had the best time.
It was just something you know. You can. I don't know if it can ever be reproduced which is why you know i think.
Are really like it if i had kids for my kids to do that and i just don't know if that would ever be out happen.
But that home. Maybe i know the whole energy that everything just was so even though it was new and things went wrong.
It wasn't a problem and i think that john and i now carry that.